We're at the zoo.
We're going to the zoo.
Creepy zoo.
Creepy creature zoo.
Hello, everybody.
I'm Minta.
Minky.
Minky, Minky, Minky.
Thank you.
Haven't been able to catch a stream for a while.
I've been super excited to see you at Opcoy.
Thank you.
Little Swamp Girls, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Guys... I don't feel well today.
My tummy hurts.
I think I possessed someone who ate something bad.
Now my tummy hurts.
I don't feel well.
Tummy hurt.
That might be on me.
Sorry, that was me.
Sorry about that.
What are you guys eating?
I'm lactose intolerant at dairy today.
Aw, man.
My tummy hurt.
But it's okay.
Just because of that, I'm a little low energy.
Because I've just been like...
Tommy hurt.
But I didn't want to not stream.
So...
Yeah.
Come possess me.
I'll give you good food.
What you got?
What are you...
I...
Will you cook for me?
But yeah.
Good thing I chose a pretty chill game.
Planet Zoo.
How...
Last time I played Zoo Tycoon.
And...
So many people...
It didn't really work out for me.
And so many people were like...
You should try Planet Zoo instead.
Not lactose intolerant, but did...
Why would you tell me that?
This must be a really good zoo...
If it can occupy a whole planet.
Yeah.
Zoo.
I mean...
Nakitori.
Nettles, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Hope your tummy feels better soon.
Luckily it's a chill game.
Yeah.
We're just gonna chill today.
We're gonna chill and...
Um...
Hold on.
Let me spray this real quick.
I'm not sure how long it will be.
It might actually be quite a short stream.
We'll see.
But I wanna...
I wanna just hang out with you guys.
Since I won't have streams for...
A little bit.
Um...
A little over a week.
So...
But after...
After Off Kai...
After this coming trip...
While streams will still be...
A little limited because...
Of my...
Throat.
Um...
I will...
Not be traveling.
So...
Or rather...
There will be no more...
Long Japan trips.
So...
It will feel...
A little more...
Back to normal...
Than me...
Streaming for two days...
And then...
Taking off...
Streaming for a day...
And...
You know...
So...
Hmm...
Today's menu is ravioli.
Ravioli...
Make Minto's...
Tummy...
Hurty...
Only...
That's probably what you said.
Creepy creatures?
More like...
Freaky creatures.
Cause...
Wisps are just that...
Kind of...
Beast.
That's the virus.
And thank you.
So...
It's been a little awkward.
I feel...
I feel like...
Uh...
Like a failure of a streamer at the moment.
Because I'm not streaming at all.
But...
It will return...
More back to normal.
Soon.
Yes, yes, yes.
Soon, soon, soon.
And...
If I see you at Off Kai...
Uh...
This weekend.
Very cool.
I think you may have possessed me.
My throat hurts.
That's not me.
Mine is not contagious.
We love Minto.
Thank you.
Spectral tummy robes.
Don't touch my tummy.
But yeah...
Um...
Uh...
What was I gonna say?
I don't remember.
There's a few things also...
That I will also be...
Doing.
Such as...
Fantastic Reality.
Which is a concert happening during...
Anime Expo.
But not at Anime Expo.
So you don't need an Anime Expo ticket to get in.
Which...
Oh my god.
I saw the ticket prices today.
For AX.
And I was like...
It's so...
Holy...
Cow.
It's...
Expensive.
Yikes.
This is so expensive.
Hmm...
It's way more...
I...
The last time I went to AX...
Well...
Okay.
Hold on.
The last time I went to AX, I got an industry badge.
But I still had to pay for it.
That's how that works.
It's very strange.
Um...
I guess if...
Unless you're a guest...
You have to...
You know...
Pay for it.
Um...
But uh...
The time before that...
I...
I would sometimes work like...
Booths at...
Anime Expo.
So...
Honestly...
I don't remember ever having to pay for...
A badge.
I never knew how expensive they were.
The only thing you're failing at...
Is disappointing.
Yeah...
I'm failing at disappointing you.
Haven't been to AX since 2018.
And it was cramped AF then.
Oh!
Last year!
It was pretty streamlined.
I thought.
No?
Wasn't that what...
One of the compliments people had?
So...
They said that it wasn't...
Bad.
In terms of the lines.
You're failing to convince us of your failure.
2024 was great.
2023 was a bit of a mess.
I didn't go...
I think I went...
20...
Either 18 or 2019.
And then obviously I didn't go...
For a couple years because of Covid.
And then I went last year.
Which was great!
That I went last year.
Because I got to meet...
Mitsukio-san.
Composer for Blue Archive.
And I got to give him my card.
And then I contacted him afterwards.
And I said...
Hey!
I would like to work with you.
Would you be interested in...
Doing my intro song?
And then he said...
Ah!
I usually...
Don't work with like...
Independent people.
But...
I really...
Like that you came up to me at...
Anime Expo.
And...
I like...
Your look...
And your vibe.
So I'll work with you.
Ha ha ha!
So it...
Honestly it was worth it.
Just for that.
Ha ha ha!
It was worth it.
Just for that.
Yeah, yeah.
Ha ha ha!
Arigato!
Choo!
That's my OCR trash talking.
Watch your mouth.
Ha ha ha!
Taking care of your health isn't failing.
Well, it's not...
It's...
Me traveling doesn't feel like I'm taking care of my health so much.
But...
I will be gone and...
And...
My voice will be needed for things...
That I'm gone...
For.
So...
Ha ha ha!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
Wait, did I miss a birthday?
I'm so sorry.
Wait, I'm going, I'm going.
Well, you're not streaming the rest of the week.
Thursday is my birthday!
But more importantly, it's Garfield's birthday.
Could you say happy early birthday to our lord and savior?
Ha ha ha!
Kayvon!
I'm sorry.
I won't be streaming on your birthday.
But happy birthday!
And happy birthday, Garfield.
I hope he has lots of lasagna.
Oh my gosh.
Isn't he so lucky that his birthday is not on a Monday?
I can tell you are good.
You are cooking and recovering your voice.
Yeah.
The moment I tuned into streams, my headache disappeared.
Ha!
Wow.
Magic.
That's the moi moi magic.
Obviously.
Actually, traveling and taking care of your mental health is not failing.
Um...
I...
I'm tired of travel.
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
Let me create my avatar while I talk.
Ha ha ha ha.
Random.
Oh.
Wow.
I feel like I'm in The Sims all of a sudden.
Hmm.
Teen.
I'm...
I'm forever...
Uh...
Forever 19.
So...
Well, technically that's teen.
Cause it has...
Nineteen.
But...
Um...
That's an adult.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Can you make eat Tina here?
Ha!
Willing well.
You read my mind!
Uh...
What is this?
Slim or...
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
This is so...
What?
You can be slim or you can be large.
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
Okay.
That's one way to put it.
I guess.
Ha ha ha.
Let's see if we can make eat Tina.
Can we...
Oh.
Wait.
Look at them chompers.
She's got like little vampire teeth.
Wait.
Where are your vampire teeth?
I could see them in this tiny little preview.
Why is she so shocked?
You know what?
Actually I would be shocked too if I had instant plastic surgery.
I think that's just the head shape.
Oh...
You're right.
Okay.
Eat Tina has...
Oh.
Uh...
Pretty...
It's like...
Her head is like the shape of a chestnut.
Wait.
An upside down chestnut.
So it's...
Big on the top and then...
Becomes small.
I think this might be our closest one.
What is this?
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Cute.
Wait.
That's actually so cute.
Oh.
This is hair.
I thought it was like...
The wrinkles.
So you asked what kind of animal you'd be not too long ago.
What kind of...
What animal do you think you'd be then?
I don't know.
That's why I asked.
I was like...
What kind of animal energy do I give?
Many people said minky.
Or like a mink.
And of course some people said monkey.
Cause minky.
Hmm.
I got a new bookshelf for my Choba figure.
Oh my gosh.
Maya.
The one where she's on the telephone pole.
I'm so jealous.
Actually, I wanted that figure so bad.
But when I saw it, it was...
It was sold out.
How...
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Okay, there we go.
I think this is the most...
Actually, I think I want to make me.
I think I want to make me.
It's my...
What's my head shape?
I want to have vampire teeth.
I guess this looks kind of...
Why does she look so old?
Why are all these hairstyles like...
Old lady?
Like look at that.
I look like a grandma.
Maybe the ponytail is the nicest one.
Oh, this is also a ponytail.
I thought it was Karen.
You got Karen one.
Karen two.
We all know Minky 3.0 has a huge forehead.
Oh, I thought you meant about my second outfit.
I was like, no!
You can't see my forehead in my next outfit.
Maybe I can make it...
Hold on.
What's...
Wait, what does this do?
Oh.
Oh, indeed.
Why does it sound like a skelly man?
Minecraft skelly man.
Look.
You can become Cruella de Vil.
This one is just absolute Karen territory.
Are there more colors or just pink?
Just...
Just this?
I don't know what to go with.
All of these are bad.
Some of these are so bad.
Oh my god.
It gets worse.
Here, we'll give ourselves some cool glasses.
And a ponytail.
I would like to speak to the...
To the designer of this game.
What the hell is this?
What is this shirt?
What kind of design is this?
Oh, look.
Oh, we can have a spooky t-shirt.
Wait, this is great.
We'll have a spooky tee.
It's like a monkey.
Womb shirt.
Maybe a kangaroo.
If it's supposed to be a kangaroo...
Like a kangaroo, they should have like a little...
Baby kangaroo peeking out.
Wait, the turtleneck is kind of nice.
But we'll go with the spooky shirt.
When you have a xenomorph in your belly.
Wow.
Legs.
These shorts are...
Wait.
Oh, wow.
I guess if this is like a uniform, it works, right?
Wait, does this come with matching pants?
Oh, it does!
Okay, I guess we know what we're wearing.
Wait, why does it show something different here?
Shows a bunch of eyeballs.
Oh!
Clown!
Why are these the default colors?
Dangerously cheesy.
That brown shirt is maternity wear.
It's got a Death Stranding style window on the belly.
So you can see BB!
I'm kind of sad that everything happened so...
Oh my god.
Wait.
This is awesome.
Everything happened so...
Much at once so that I couldn't...
Play Death Stranding in time for the release.
Wait!
A snake!
Oh, that's not a snake.
That's the logo for Planet Zoo.
Okay, I will go with the frog.
Wait, what about my hair?
Can I change my hair then?
Oh, nope.
You're stuck with it.
Why is there a little dot here?
Okay.
I guess I must accept this.
Because that's what it says.
Except...
I'm accepting...
Like...
Wow.
These are some...
Crazy hats.
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, it is ice cream!
You could just have a big old...
Scoop of ice cream.
Everybody wants a hat of...
Brown ice cream.
Definitely doesn't look like anything else on top of your head.
Are you sure?
There she goes!
So, I should also say...
I've never played this game before.
So...
Place your avatar HQ.
The HQ is where other players will see your avatar and access any zoos or boop...
Blueprints you have...
Sh...
I said booprints.
I'm a ghost!
Position your avatar anywhere on the globe.
You can edit the avatar HQ position later.
Okay, there's this one island.
I think it's...
I don't think that's it.
It's about here, I believe.
It's like the most remote island in the world.
The closest human beings to it are...
Are...
The humans on the ISS.
So...
We'll go there.
Is it Point Nemo?
I don't remember the name.
Let me Google.
Perfect place for a zoo.
Exactly!
Whoa.
Point...
Nemo...
South Pacific Ocean.
Yeah.
I guess like...
We'll do like...
Right here.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Okay!
Hi!
What should we do?
Career?
Progressor?
And...
Hey!
Who are you?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
People are invading.
Yeah, I got an achievement for placing my person.
We could do career.
We could do...
I don't think I wanna do timed.
Build zoos all over the world and trade your animals online.
Build your zoos offline with a full economy and challenges.
Sandbox!
Maybe Sandbox mode would be good.
Yeah, let's just do that so we can build the...
Zoo of my dreams.
Scenario zoo.
Goodwin house.
We need at least one star on the previous levels.
Hope sa- Wait!
Castle Myers.
This looks spooky.
Easter Island Minto Zoo.
Zoo in the middle of the ocean.
Just like Mother Base.
Exactly!
When I start fultoning all the animals, this is where they go.
Creepy zoo.
Clear the zoo of all scenario items.
What's the difficulty?
I mean...
Animals never get bored of enrichment items.
Guests won't request refuds.
Sorry, I was checking up on my cat.
I guess we'll try it.
You know what, whatever.
I'm just here to vibe today.
Why does it sound like a Coca-Cola commercial?
Do-do-dee.
New sandbox settings.
More settings.
Oh, by the way.
I have this castle area because I bought DLC.
This game...
Has, first of all, so much DLC.
At first I was like...
It's kind of pricey.
But...
I really just wanted...
Your zoo has no vets to deal with all the...
Ill or...
I have...
Ill animals?
There's so much DLC and it's...
Expensive!
To get all the DLC for this game?
It's...
Two...
Two hundred dollars!
What?!
There!
It's nuts!
Yeah...
So I just bought one.
Um...
Can I move...
Whoa!
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Uh...
How do I...
Oh, gosh.
Oh, golly.
How do I move the camera?
I don't know anything right now.
Basic controls!
Select...
Okay...
Cancel...
Undo...
Control Z...
Redo...
Control Y...
Okay...
Uh...
Six out of...
Twenty-three!
Okay...
Oh, shift!
Oh!
Just kidding.
I'm pressing shift.
Oh!
There's a crime scene.
What is happening?
Uh...
Oh!
Oh, gosh.
Okay...
I won't get...
I'm not gonna get...
I'm not gonna get sick.
Why if I press...
Oh!
My fingers weren't on...
I was like...
Why if I press...
Back?
It's going...
Or if I press...
Left?
It's going back!
Because my fingers weren't on...
Washed up!
Oh, my bad!
Where's the entrance to this park?
Why are there so many...
Dead little foxes?
Rotate 90 degrees...
Oh, that didn't do anything...
How do I like...
Turn?
Turn around?
Fox die?
Maybe I guess like this.
Okay, so this is the entrance, no?
No.
Wait, this is the entrance.
Yeah, this is...
Where we zoomed through.
How are people getting here?
We don't have a parking lot.
We've got nothing.
Go do the tutorial?
I didn't see a tutorial.
Who is Zohan?
Why is he taking over my...
My...
My zoo?
Microsoft Flight Simulator 2024 uses models from Planet Zoo to populate the world with animals.
That's so cute, actually.
Let's see what we got going on here.
Do I have any animals?
I have fake animals.
It's paper mache wombat.
That thing's gonna break.
Probably, right?
The thing...
All it has to do is rain once.
And it's gonna be Jell-O.
Wow.
This place is actually really cute.
I didn't have the box...
I...
Wait.
I haven't had the...
I don't have to build anything.
Maybe I should have sandboxed with, like, nothing.
Wait, there's...
There's everything here that anybody could ever need.
Who's the king?
Who the hell is a Vinny?
Get out of my zoo.
It's not ready yet.
This is a RPG city.
Oh, you guys seen that Jenny Nicholson video about that...
Ever...
Evermore...
Everquest...
What was that place called?
Evermore?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna zoom out some more so we can get, like, a full view.
Where am I supposed to put any exhibits?
Down in the caves?
Wait, wait, wait.
What is this?
A generator?
A transformer?
Robots in disguise.
Wait, what's down here?
Love this game after seeing Iggyo play it.
I don't know who that is.
Is my zoo open?
They can come in and see the cute fake animals.
Oh, sorry.
I'm trying to get inside the cave.
Oh, what?
Who are you people?
What?
What a beautiful place.
Wait, where did all these people come from?
I thought we only had one visitor.
Are you also going home?
Our place is not...
Wait, is this the exit up here?
How do you leave?
I don't think this is the exit, you guys.
How are you gonna get home?
Beep boop.
This is...this feels like hard mode.
Wait, they're going this way.
What are you doing?
You're just wandering.
Strangest episode of Beast Wars ever.
Minto's spit and greet line leaked.
Shut up.
It feels so magical and beautiful.
Why are there such so many people though?
They seem to like the park.
Everybody's got big ol' smiles.
What are you saying?
Oh, you're going home.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot how to go up again.
Please send me up.
Oh.
Send me up.
Where did all these people come from is my question.
How did they get inside?
Did they travel?
Well...
I...I...
We definitely didn't see them travel from in here.
Shift up down.
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
I should go do the tutorial, huh?
Let's go to the tutorial.
It's fine, we didn't do anything.
We just looked around.
I'm gonna do the tutorial.
Update.
Education stations.
Oh my gosh.
One out of 41.
Piebaldism.
A new special coat jean.
My... my deer are going to go bald.
Exhibit talks.
Exhibit camera.
That's fun.
Looking forward to the 100 men versus 1 gorilla attraction.
We can make that right now.
Where is the tutorial?
Maybe in the career.
No.
This game is acting like I'm a genius or something.
Career first level.
Oh really?
Okay.
Oh.
Some would say bald.
Fully trained a member of staff.
Yeah, I did that.
We're at university.
Oh, it's voiced.
I have a habit of slipping back into the Planko language.
It's good to finally meet you in person.
I'm Bernard.
Although I insist you call me Bernie.
Bernie.
The only person who calls me Bernard is my wife.
And even then, only when I've tracked elephant dung into the carpet.
Ew.
They don't take off your shoes?
Bad human.
I own several zoos.
But I always like to show people the robes here at my home.
Can't put your own fan base in a zoo.
Watch me.
This is the first zoo I ever opened.
And a source of great pride for me.
And prides.
Thanks to a lion breeding program we ran in the 80s.
Oh, I'm watching that lion take a shit.
But we're in the middle of a big renovation.
And that's where you come in.
Sadly, our old contractor had to retire after the development of fur allergy.
No!
The devil kept sneezing his dentures into the lion habitat.
That's nature, I guess.
So, it's up to you to finish everything off.
Don't worry though.
I'm not completely throwing you in at the deep end.
Okay.
My head keeper, Nancy Jones, will be lending a helping hand.
Oh my god, sometimes I watch nature live cams.
And she would expect you to be too.
And there's this one of a watering hole in Africa.
But I'm sure we get along with the house on fire.
Even better.
I think it's...
One that isn't on fire.
Less shouting that way.
And I'm...
Hello there.
From that rosy, fresh face of yours, I'm guessing...
But today...
You're Bernie's new hire.
Good.
Now, I hope you're ready to ditch your diploma, because we're about to get...
Let me be a one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But before we begin the real work...
I watched that one.
How about we familiarize you with it?
And today...
By learning how to fly around it.
And visiting some of our beautiful animals.
Okay.
We'll start by popping over and having a look-see at the grizzly bears in their habitat.
Today...
Uh...
It was just...
Covered entirely by a spider for like hours.
The spider got really comfy and was like, yep.
Okay.
So we're gonna go find the grizzly bears, which are totally highlighted.
I'm here.
Oh.
Did you know that grizzly bears, also known as Ursus Arctos Horribilis...
How do I turn around?
Can hibernate for up to seven months a year.
Oh, here we go.
Oh.
But then again, given the chance, I think a lot of people would do that too.
Ha ha ha.
So true.
Select one of the bears, and you'll bring up its information panel.
Oh, there's an animal camera.
Enter grizzly bear animal camera.
Possession.
I will possess this guy's body.
This is where you can find out all kinds of information about your animal.
The most important thing being its overall welfare.
We'll learn more about animal welfare today as we go through your objectives.
But for now, let's enjoy this magnificent animal.
Why don't you select the camera at the bottom of its information panel?
What is this?
See now, this is a fantastic way to get a close look at your animals.
Wait, I'm so far away.
You can also get this view of an animal by simply double clicking on it.
Okay, when you're ready, let's pop over to the other side of the zoo.
Look at him go.
I've marked their location for you to find.
Wow, this is just like my animal cameras, but better.
Oh, so cute.
Are you going to sleep?
He's so cute.
I love how in these Nat games they talk.
Super chill like a Nat Geo documentary.
Yeah, right.
We got a friend.
Okay, I thought he was going to...
I keep thinking they're going to poo in their beds, you know.
How do I get out of the bed?
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
Nice.
Locate the West African lion exhibit.
Goodbye, Zachary.
Wait, what is this?
A balloon!
Goodbye.
Okay, over there.
Come on, we put the freak phantom.
We'll put him.
Panfera, Leo, Leo.
All the West African lion to you and me.
Lions are the most social of the big cats.
And they can be as many as 40 lions in a pride.
Although cats of that size are pretty rare.
As Bernie would say, those lions are rawsome.
Rawsome.
There's only two in here?
Anyway, how about we get started on those objectives?
Come on, let's head over to an empty habitat.
Oh, I think that's a fake zebra.
Oh, can I possess the person?
No.
Oh wait, yes I can.
What are you doing?
Mister?
Okay.
Let's see.
What were our objectives?
I lost them.
Uh oh, wait.
Oh no.
Ma'am?
Oh, I found them.
Just kidding.
Uh, locate the empty habitat.
How do I go up?
Why do people keep...
Keep losing their balloons?
Oh my gosh.
I'm so bad at moving this camera.
Damn, this place is crowded.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Empty.
There.
This is a crowded zoo.
As you can see, it's a lovely space for animals, but it's missing a certain something.
An animal?
Two somethings.
Warthogs.
Oh.
So I'd like you to adopt a pair of them.
Why can't I adopt what I want?
We need to open the animal market, which is in the animal trading section.
Okay.
Animal trading.
There we are.
A pair of perfectly splendid Warthogs for our zoo.
Just click on them and select adopt from the side menu.
Normally the animal exchange would be full of animals, but I've emptied out the market while you learn how it works.
I want to.
The last thing I made is you accidentally ordering a dozen elephants.
That's what I wanted to do.
When you adopt an animal, it's automatically placed in the trade center, where they're held until you're ready to move them into their habitat.
Okay.
As it happens, you are.
So how about you move them into their new home?
Send.
Okay.
When you ask for an animal to be moved into a habitat, your caretakers will go to the trade center.
collect your animal and deliver them to your selected habitat.
And mark the trade center's location.
So let's go and watch the caretakers in action.
Where?
Um.
Uh.
Oh.
Right there.
Oh my god.
Whoa.
They'll move those animals to their destination as fast as possible.
Oh my god.
It's so good without...
That warthog is getting shaken up.
Oh my god.
But I am assured by a person of good standing that these warthogs are in the very rudest of health.
Right.
Let's get the warthogs habitat finished up so we can keep...
Oh he's running around.
Oh my god.
And he throws them in the air.
It's hungry and thirsty.
That way you'll know exactly what areas need to be addressed.
Don't worry if that's a lot to remember.
You can always check the zoopedia for more information.
Okay.
So we need more...
Hold on my head.
Let's start by making sure we're taking care of the warthogs' nutrition welfare.
To do this, we'll need to place a food station and a drinking station.
Now, each animal requires a different type of feeding station.
Oh wow.
And for the warthogs, it's a small feeding trough.
So let's add one of those and a water bowl.
Okay.
How?
Habitat?
Oh, food trough.
Small.
We'll put it close to so that everybody can watch him eat.
And then, um, the large water bowl.
Animals also require stimulation to keep them happy.
Let's add a lovely mud bath for the warthogs to roll around in.
That bath will count towards their enrichment welfare.
Specifically, their toy enrichment welfare.
Oh wow!
This is huge!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh!
Nice work!
You've got a knack for this, I see.
Okay, I feel like I already know how to play this game.
Now, I will contract to have to leave in a hurry, so this place is in a pharaoh state.
Unfinished thingamajigs and wotsits all over the shop.
But the first thing we need to finish is the ostrich habitat.
It's over near the hippos.
Wait, but I'm...
These guys have nothing.
These guys need more grass.
They want more long grass.
Oh wait, there's nothing available.
They want more soil?
Oh wait, they have too much soil.
Animal needs less soil.
They're unhappy!
They're hungry and thirsty!
Oh, they're thirsty!
Terrain bottom right.
Oh, I see it.
Thank you.
So, they want some long grass.
Is this too much?
Size 2.
Uh...
Am I doing it?
I don't think I am.
Uh...
Um...
No!
Maybe it's locked for now.
It might be.
Okay.
What did you want me to do?
Oh!
The ostrich.
So, there's paths here.
Terrain.
Blueprints.
Construction.
Facilities.
Okay.
Ostrich.
Where are they?
Oh, before we actually start building our ostrich habitat...
Oh!
It's not finished.
Let's pause the game.
Just click the pause button in the bottom right corner.
Nan...
Nancy, is this a game to you?
Am I a joke?
Is this a game to you?
Animals are starving.
That's more like it.
A quick break.
Sometimes it's a good idea to pause the game whilst you're doing something which requires your concentration.
Because it'll stop the zoo spinning out of control while you're looking the other way.
Let's keep the game paused while we get this ostrich habitat built.
Okay.
Job number one here is to add a habitat gate before we complete the barrier.
Every habitat needs a habitat gate.
Ooh, this guy almost walked in.
After all, how else would the keepers get in and out?
Just make sure it's hooked up to the path so the keepers can reach it.
Okay.
Vivico, thanks so much for the vibe.
Gifted.
Thank you.
I'm gonna make it.
We're gonna...
We're saving money.
What?
I can't go diagonal.
What the?
Oh, yes I can.
Uh...
What do you want me to do?
Obstructed.
By what?
Outside placement area.
Huh?
Oh, I think I messed up.
Oh, here we go.
No?
I messed up.
There's a control Z.
There we go.
Okay.
Connect the habitat to the path.
Maybe if we drive from this end.
What is outside placement area?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, I'm wanting me to add the gate first.
What?
Oh...
I see, I see.
They're just being finicky.
Obstructed!
Okay, uh...
Never...
Oh?
Oh, thank you.
I tried inside the glowing area.
It said it's obstructed.
What?
It's so picky.
Right!
Okay.
Let's complete the perimeter barrier so we can adopt us some ostriches.
I've marked out an area for you to use, so I'd like you to finish off the perimeter using the brick barrier.
Okay.
Aw, I'm even getting policed in the...
Okay, hold on.
We'll make it zig-zag.
Kind of like a cool...
Future...
I can't see.
Oh, gosh.
We'll just put somewhere.
And...
Complete.
Good work!
Remember, before you can place animals in any habitat, it has to have a full loop of connected barrier.
Shouldn't we have windows so people can see inside?
Now, we've probably noticed that guests can't actually see into this habitat at the moment.
At least not without a stepladder.
But seeing as they're banned, I'd like you to select a piece of barrier and swap out the brick for a glass barrier, so the guests can see in.
Yeah, that's what I was saying.
Oh, man.
They can see here.
Wait.
Section...
Highlight a section of barrier and then click the glass barrier.
There we go.
Adding in more windows gives guests even more opportunities to see the animals in a habitat.
It looks kind of unsafe.
It's always best to make sure the guests can get a good view into a habitat from the path they're walking on.
Because it makes them happy.
Oh, it goes behind.
And because this would be a pretty terrible zoo if they couldn't.
The last thing we need to do is to add a donation box.
You see, when guests enjoy the view of an animal, they'll make a donation.
Just make sure you put them in easy to reach places like near a viewing point.
Oh, we're gonna put a lot of those.
Donation boxes are one of the main sources of income for the zoo, so make sure you remember them.
Okay.
Now, before we adopt our ostriches, you should click the play button.
After all, if the games pause, then so are our caretakers, which will make it a bit tricky for them to deliver the ostriches.
Donation box, everybody donate!
Outside placement area.
No, I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure we're in the placement area.
Okay.
The game is really gatekeeping me right now.
Um...
Okay.
Unpause time.
By the way, as well as pausing the game, you can speed the game up by clicking on the fast forward button.
It's just like the Sims.
It'll run everything at two times and five times faster.
It can be useful, especially if you're waiting for money to accumulate or for animals to be delivered to your habitat.
Don't know for viewing, Minky.
I'm Minky!
And I'm in the glass cage!
Alright, you've finished the habitat, so it's high time we adopted those ostriches, don't you think?
Yes.
Let's get four of them in here.
Four?
Uh...
Where are they at?
Where do I buy the...
Here?
What if I get a cheetah?
Wait, this is...
Oh, it's a Brazilian spider.
I was gonna say, this is the spider that was on the camera today.
I think they would like to have a little...
Little friend in here as well.
With them.
We'll give...
Okay, nobody will notice the snail, you know?
Wait, actually, how do I buy again?
I don't...
Oh, animal trading.
Here we go.
Oh, come on.
No, no.
Snail.
No, snail!
Minetal.
It's my donation for the Great Mint Phantom Zoo.
Thank you.
If they like the Warthog exhibit, five star would recommend visiting again.
Alright.
Wait.
Send the zoo.
Wait a second.
Source comments.
Oh!
I was like...
Oh no!
I think our guy is sick!
He gets seizures!
Nah.
Send to zoo.
One of our guys is a fancy fellow.
Him.
While we wait for them to be collected by the caretakers and brought to the habitat, you should get ready for them.
Take the following.
Big cat cafe.
Add a suitable feeding station, water station, and an appropriate food enrichment item.
Okay.
It's often best to place things like enrichments and feeding stations near to the habitat perimeter, so guests can get a really good view of the animals.
Yeah, I thought about that earlier.
Oh!
Where are they coming from?
Stop throwing around my animals like this.
What's your name?
Normal.
Delivered.
Enjoy your new home, little body.
Oh, here he comes.
Oh, here they come.
The marathon.
Okay.
I need to put in habitat.
A slow feeder.
I don't think they'll like that, but you know.
And then...
Nature.
What else do they want?
Water station, feeding station.
Oh, here we go.
And...
Water.
Perfect!
Oh!
Will there be an exhibition for wisps and dragoons?
Maybe.
Dang!
Our zoo is...
Wow!
Okay, I feel like I'm done.
I'm impressed.
Did you do a speed camera joke?
Every time we get an ostrich.
Enough of the tutorial.
You know?
So, now we've made the ostrich's lives a bit better.
Let's do the same for the keepers, shall we?
To make it easier for the keepers to feed the ostriches and hippos...
Oh, they're also part of the zoo.
We should build a new keeper hut.
Keeper huts are where the keepers prepare the food for animals.
So they should be placed near to the habitats.
To make sure the keepers don't waste their time walking when they should be looking after the animals.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Facilities.
Small hut.
We'll go with this.
It matches the...
Oh, no.
That's not that.
You'll need to rotate the keeper hut to get it to connect up to the path.
Oh.
Okay.
Rotate.
Wow.
So fancy.
Okay.
Good.
This keeper hut only has space for one keeper.
There were no servos unless they added in the DLC.
Yeah.
But the larger keeper hut can allow multiple keepers to prepare food at the same time.
Oh, but bear in mind that keeper huts and other staff facilities shouldn't be placed near to areas where there are lots of guests.
Guests don't like seeing facility buildings and it can affect their happiness.
Oh.
Negatively.
In case that wasn't clear.
Okay.
What?
Why don't they like seeing buildings?
Bottom left.
Lovely work.
Now the keepers can start using the hut to prepare food.
My immersion.
And thanks to where you've put it, they wouldn't need to walk very far to deliver it to the ostriches and hippos.
I think the animals in cages breaks my immersion.
Bengal tigers.
We want to adopt some, but I'm afraid there's nothing ready for them yet.
She does have a bit of a threatening undertone, doesn't she?
Head on over to the plot of land I've marked out.
It's not too far away.
Oh, I think we need to get rid of this.
Okay, there we go.
Here?
Oh, we're actually like...
Righty.
Your next job is to build a habitat from scratch.
And concrete and glass I expect.
So, go ahead and build it.
Just make sure that the habitat includes that big hole we've dug.
Oh.
And don't forget to add a habitat gate to the barrier.
Okay.
Oh, and make sure the guests will be able to see the tigers.
Oh my gosh.
Nancy.
I got this girl.
Let's see.
Full glass.
All glass.
Oh, it's the best habitat you've ever seen.
You'll see it from every angle.
Oh, oh.
So close.
Come on.
How am I supposed to make these connect?
Oh wait.
Uh, shoot.
Hold on.
Um...
How do they connect?
No privacy?
They don't...
They don't find their tigers.
Okay.
And then we need a gate.
Oh, where...
Oh, oh.
Wait.
What is this?
A transformer.
Okay.
Um...
We'll have it here.
For the...
Um...
For the zookeepers.
And I guess we gotta build a path.
Otherwise they're gonna get really...
Really...
Upset.
They're like little babies.
They need to be...
Handheld.
Where'd it go?
Now...
Burnie takes safety very seriously at his zoos.
So we should probably make sure those tigers can't jump out of their habitat.
Don't you think?
They won't.
The way we'll do it...
Is by changing the height of the habitat's barrier.
Oh.
Okay then.
You should start by double clicking the habitat barrier.
Which will take you into barrier editing mode.
Great.
Now highlight the entire perimeter of the habitat.
How do I do that?
By clicking and dragging the barrier selection tool.
Barrier selection tool.
Uh...
The arrows?
Ah.
Now you've got all of the perimeter selected.
You can increase the height of it by clicking and dragging the barrier height tool upwards.
There we go.
You want to make sure it reaches a height of at least 3.7 meters.
I'll do you better.
I'll triple that number and give it to the next person.
Please don't forget to put down a donation box.
Oh yeah.
We need every dollar we can get.
She big about that money.
Especially as these tigers aren't exactly eating instant noodles for lunch.
Okay.
That's the habitat boundary complete.
The habitat gate in place.
And most importantly, the tigers won't be able to jump out of it anymore.
I think it's time we adopted those tigers.
Oh my goodness.
Can I see?
I don't think people will be able to go over there.
Can they go here?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, what were we doing?
Oh, getting our tigers.
Alright.
Animals.
Wow, they're expensive.
Can we have a coyote, a dire wolf, and a humble penguin?
I don't think I bought those DLCs.
Okay, for habitat.
Food tray large.
This time, instead of adding a water bowl, let's try something different.
Ooh.
Some animals need a pool in their habitat so they can go for a swim, but they can also use it to drink from.
All you have to do is make sure the banks of the pool have a gentle slope so they can easily get a nice refreshing drink.
Okay.
There's already a pool excavated, but you still need to fill it with water.
You should do that by going into terrain and selecting the water tool.
Water.
Yes, that'll do nicely.
That's it?
Of course, just like the warthogs and ostriches...
They have nothing there.
It's gonna dry up in the sun.
They have some suitable toy and food enrichment items into their habitat.
Wait, wait.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, what just happened?
Okay.
I think we're fine.
I think we're okay.
Food enrichment.
Place a toy.
Frozen blood pumpkin.
What is it obstructed by?
Oh, here.
There we go.
The controls are a little...
I gotta get used to it, but...
And a rubbing pad.
There's nothing in here, Nancy.
Now, the tigers will need a shelter in their habitat, so they can hide from the guests.
Or, more likely, the bad weather.
Ah, more likely the guests.
You might want to think of that just as normal weather.
Go on, add a shelter to their habitat.
This is huge!
You can need to build one from various suitable bits and bobs, or if you like, just pop down the blueprint that I've already built for you.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's humongous.
I'm gonna block these people's view.
Oh, poor dabs.
Poor guy.
I'm sure it can't have escaped your attention that the tigers look a bit miffed.
Why?
That's because they aren't too keen on the type of terrain in their habitat.
Yeah, because you said everything was fine, Nancy, when it wasn't.
Goodness gracious.
Even I knew that the- Right here.
That way you can view the terrain information and see how they feel about the different types of terrain.
That'll tell you what the tigers need more of or less of in this habitat.
They need more long grass.
Okay then, open the terrain editing tool, select painting, and give them some more soil.
Yes, that should help with the habitat part of their welfare.
Did that work?
Oh, here we go.
Okay, it's going up, it's going up.
What do you think of...
Boca Juniors?
Of who?
What's that?
Oh wait, we have too much...
Grass.
Okay, we need more...
Soil.
Uh...
Is this the correct soil?
Okay, it's...
It's...
It's going down.
This is what they like.
Not enough short grass.
Oh my gosh, these guys are so picky.
Yeah!
Looks like a baseball field.
I should have made it.
Kittens in the outfield.
These tigers need a few more plants in their habitat.
To get a perfect fit, use plants from the rainforest and temperate biomes that are native to Asia.
Although if you have to, you can get away with using just one or the other.
The tigers will also want a certain amount of their habitat to be covered by those plants.
To find out which plants to use and how many, select a tiger and go to the environment tab.
Okay.
I kind of miss how...
As you can see, some of the plants currently in the habitat aren't quite right for the tiger.
Please!
Like the wattle bushes.
You can remove them if you want.
I kind of miss how...
You can find all of the plants you need in the nature section.
And you can use the filters to only show the types of plants you want to see.
In this case, that's plants from the rainforest or temperate biomes.
I kind of miss how in...
How in Zoo Tycoon...
They'll be like...
Wee!
When they're...
When they're sad.
This is Nancy's stream.
Please don't talk, weep duck.
Whatever.
Do they like an elephant ear?
They have no opinion.
Wait, what do you like?
Okay, we need more coverage.
Where did I see...
Oh, here, here, here.
Okay.
Plants and habitat.
Oh, some...
Okay, so some of them aren't great.
Like the spruce tree, they hate it.
Let's do some ferns.
Oh!
Oh wow, that was so easy.
They say that good fences make good neighbors.
I guess that's doubly true when one of the neighbors is a Bengal tiger.
Still, those tigers look so happy that I doubt they'd leave.
Even if you did poke a hole in their fence.
Okay.
Oh.
But for heaven's sake, don't test that theory.
Thanks, Bernie.
I think I'm gonna stop...
Oh, no.
Shut up, Nancy.
Nancy, shut up.
Nancy.
Nancy, I wanna go back home.
Exit to main menu.
I think we're good with the tutorial.
No more Nancy.
Nancy.
I don't...
I can't deal with her anymore.
I can't...
Okay, I think we're now good.
Whoa.
Who was that?
Wait.
The people were replaced by animals.
What?
Oh.
This is me.
This is...
Wait, this is a career scenario.
I thought it was the one that I was doing earlier.
Bye, Nancy.
See?
Huh.
How long do you think it'll be before she unleashes tigers and the zoo visitors?
I don't wanna do a career, though.
I wanna do my own thing, you know?
So we will go away from...
My zoo.
Oh, these are the good ones.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Back, back, back.
Sandbox.
And we're gonna do a scenario.
And we're gonna do the castle myers.
And we're...
Clear all zoo of scenario items.
I wonder what it'll look like then.
The spooky zoo.
I don't remember why I named it before.
Nancy is set to free room.
She just...
Talks and talks.
I'd throw her into the lava.
I wonder what terrain only...
I don't wanna get rid of some of the spooky things, but...
I guess we'll just buy them back, huh?
What if I create a zoo of one really cool animal?
I think people would wanna come and see it.
Nancy.
Let's do it.
What animal?
I don't know.
We'll have to see what we got.
I'm excited to see the terrain now.
Oh!
There's a whole lot of nothing.
Oh, wow.
Oh!
How much money do we have?
Um...
Unlimited?
No way!
We have unlimited money?
Wait, but that's not really how you play the game.
I want a...
Bit of a budget.
Spend!
Let's see what animals we got.
Wait, zoo.
Animals.
Okay, here we go.
None.
Why wouldn't it let me go to...
Oh, maybe I have to make a barrier first before we go into the animal...
Trading.
Sandbox mode is unlimited.
What?
Uh...
Okay, hold on then.
Ambient speaker...
Okay.
What's our spooky stuff here?
Oh my gosh, can I...
Can I hide all the things that require DLC?
Okay, here we go.
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
Gopi slush.
What is that?
Oh my god!
The person just came out from there!
Oh, and he's gone.
He quit.
First day on the job, he couldn't handle it.
Oh, we'll do a second guy.
Right next to him.
It's kind of majestic with this music and watching them just disappear.
Here?
I'm trying to get my, uh...
Oh.
Street fox fox...
Coffee...
Counter.
Trying to get my spooky things.
Twilight...
See, see, see, see, see, see.
Like this, like this.
Okay.
Can I get rid of this place?
Delete.
Or they have to just...
They'll go through a second entrance.
It's all good.
They can do it.
One entrance into the next entrance.
Wait, how do I...
What?
How do you...
Where is it?
Eh?
You walk in, but where do you walk out?
Huh?
Oh wait, right here.
Huh.
Is it working?
Oh, no.
He's trying.
You can do it.
I feel like I'm watching like a...
Guy trying to harness his superpowers for the first time ever.
What is this place then?
Oops.
There we go.
Then you go through...
And it leads you...
To...
What?
Why are there no exits?
It says zoo entrance.
Build something.
Okay.
Let's build.
We'll do...
I don't know...
Chain link.
Circle.
There we go.
Okay.
Gate.
Alright.
And...
Do we need the facility?
There's so many things.
Going to the zoo.
Watching animals in their red shirts try to solve problems.
It's like a...
Actually looks like a heart.
That's even sweeter, huh?
Hehehe.
I love my animals.
And I love my money.
Yes, yes, yes.
I like the way you build the paths in this.
It's...
Really satisfying.
Can I...
Stop it now?
There we go.
Okay.
Facilities.
They also wanted educational things, I remember.
They want to know about whatever creature will be in here.
Which will be...
In here.
Soon.
Look!
It's so close that even...
The animal could donate if they wanted to.
Wait, why can't I go to the animal trading yet?
What am I doing wrong?
What's this?
Guest spawner.
Oh.
That's interesting.
Oh, I need to build the...
Hold on.
Let's do staff facilities.
The place where the...
They spawn, right?
Whoa.
Oh, this is huge.
It's...
It's called the staff room small.
Oh, the trade center.
Here we go, here we go.
We'll build it like right here.
Hopefully, people like it.
Terrain modification.
There we go, there we go, there we go.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
What can we get?
The giant tortoise.
Build a stage and teach the animals to sing and dance.
Just like the movie.
Sing.
A tape here.
That's all I can get?
Oh, no.
Just kidding.
Next.
Still need a staff room.
Okay.
Thank you.
Bonobo.
See that.
Hmm.
Ostrich.
We gotta get a creepy critter.
Something...
Freaky.
Like that.
These look...
Some of these look really realistic.
Like the flamingo looks really realistic.
Spider pit.
Yeah.
Peacock.
Oh.
Komodo dragon.
I think...
A monitor.
What if I just make a...
A lizard pit.
Raccoon.
That must be the DLC.
Was that a lemur?
Yeah.
More lemur.
How many pages are there?
Snow leopard.
A skunk.
Ah.
We don't have dire wolf.
But we have timber wolf.
Okay.
Let's get the...
Wait.
Where is he?
Here we go.
Komodo dragon.
This guy's got a medal.
Of honor.
Okay.
We'll hold on to him for now.
He's waiting in the trade center.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
We got the two...
Most prized...
Sought after...
Dragons.
The Covenant Lizard Award.
Lizard.
Okay, we gotta build a staff room.
Ooh, it's getting dark.
This area...
Is beautiful!
Wow.
My gosh.
How do people get up here?
Wait a second.
I just noticed...
This is where the castle was.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I think I made a mistake.
This is where the zoo was below...
Before.
And then...
The castle was up here.
Oh.
Let's see what castle we have.
Veterinary surgery.
Oh, wait.
Oh, let's do all.
Oh, we are on all.
Oh.
Guess facility?
Maybe.
Oh, no.
It's the entrance.
Getting ahead of myself.
The toilet large.
They probably need that.
This is a large toilet for real.
You two can pee right in front of the Komodo dragon.
Not as beautiful as the ghost in the right corner.
Staff.
This is a true landmark of the park.
It's ginormous.
I want to add some like...
Some of our old trees and all.
Some of our own freaky things and the...
How do I...
Oh, DLC.
Wait.
How do I know what I purchased for the DLC?
Who's here?
Oh, Staff.
Staff.
Oh, I need staff.
Okay.
I'll get by some staff.
I'll buy...
How do I buy staff?
I skipped that part of the tutorial.
Oh, here we go.
You...
And...
Security.
Buy some staff.
Maybe you should have listened to Nancy.
Nah.
Oh, my bad.
Here we go.
We have Abraham.
He's supposed to be at Gopi's soda counter one, but he's...
Actually...
Like...
Neglecting his job entirely.
I can't see...
Anything.
Facilities.
Lights.
Please.
Power.
Oh, wait.
Oh, whoa.
We need the transformer, don't we?
Or something?
I don't quite understand it.
And I know we're not supposed to put the staff room right next to...
Right next to the exhibit, but...
It's just gonna have to be the way that...
That is.
Maybe we can cover it with foliage.
Nobody will see a thing.
With...
The festive spruce...
Oh, it's so small.
Uh...
Oh, oh.
Like this.
It's like when they make those...
Um...
Those...
Uh...
Towers, but they are...
They look like trees.
Now the guests will never see the...
Um...
The...
The staff housing.
Staffing quarters.
There we go.
Oh, please.
Nancy more like...
Nancy.
She ain't listening.
Please.
How do I open the mega door?
I'm so confused about this actually.
I'm actually so confused.
Do I need to make the gate here too?
No.
They spawn from inside the entrance.
Do they?
Okay.
Well, let's get our...
Our...
Iguanas.
And we'll put them in our...
The cage.
This guy costs 58 leaves.
Nobody wants them.
Animal storage.
Okay, here we go.
Send the zoo.
And I'm gonna make this cage look amazing and great.
Not like those...
Poopy other ones.
Did I say iguana?
I meant...
Komodo dragon.
Oh yeah.
Ra...
Rara.
Alright, what do you want Rara?
You want...
More...
Long grass.
Got it.
Uh...
Am I doing it?
Why isn't it going down?
Rock?
We should build...
We should write it in a funny language.
Or something.
Hold on.
Control Z.
There we go.
Wish I could see anything.
Um...
Draw a wisp.
Looks like an apple.
Okay, more rock.
More rock.
Okay.
Almost.
Okay, sand.
You think they like sand course?
Might be easier for their little toes.
I hear people laughing.
We have customers!
I repeat.
We have customers.
This is not a drill.
Everyone's gonna be so excited.
Okay.
Now we just need more grass long.
Very carefully.
Oh, too much grass long.
We can replace it with some sand.
It's less grass long.
Oh.
Not bad.
Wait, was it from the beginning?
Less...
Less grass?
Oopsie!
We'll do short grass.
We can do more of that.
Not enough rock!
Less soil.
Too much grass long.
Ugh.
How is there still too much grass long?
Wow, these guys are so picky.
Guys, I...
Just today I was like...
Hmm, I'm kinda bored.
What do I do?
I tried playing Age of Empires.
Um...
Against some CPU.
And I got my butt whooped.
I think I'm bad at that game.
Super chato for the iguana.
Thank you!
How is there still too much grass?
Long!
I've covered this entire place.
There is no grass long anymore.
Is there?
There's literally no grass long in here anymore.
Takes practice.
Yeah.
Clearly.
Moderate AOE AI is brutal.
Oh, I like...
They were...
They were attacking me like nothing else.
They hate the sight of the grass long?
Wait, seriously?
Maybe it's because it's touching their...
Their...
Their thing.
They just hate it so much.
They're like...
It can't even touch our...
Exhibit.
We don't want it...
Any near...
Anywhere near us.
Uh...
Look how cute.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's really cute!
Oh wait, maybe some grass long over here?
I have no idea.
Wait, why is our fence so like...
Um...
Oh, there's just...
There's just a hole.
There's like a pet door for these guys.
Oh wow, this is...
Um...
This one's fine.
So is this one...
They can't...
They can't get out.
They don't even care to.
You don't care to leave, do you?
Like...
Oh, he's taking a nap.
He's recharging his energy to...
To...
For his escape plan.
This for real has many spikes.
Lower settings.
Wait for you to advance in age, for example.
Oh, yeah.
I was trying to...
They like completely ambushed me.
I was trying to like...
Start an army.
I built my castle.
And then...
They destroyed my castle twice.
Where is the grass long?
I'm actually confused now.
Oh well.
Okay.
What else do you want?
You want...
Uh...
What kind of things?
It doesn't say.
Uh oh.
It honestly feels like they have a vendetta sometimes.
I know!
And then I had an ally team too.
And they did not help even once.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Let's uh...
How do we know what they like?
Filter by...
Uh...
Biome is tropical.
And grassland.
Alright.
Maybe...
This...
This tree.
Huh.
Do they actually want more grass long?
I don't think so.
No.
Oh.
Yes.
They need more grass long.
Oops.
More grass long.
Almost there.
Wait.
Why does it feel like the bar is moving?
Am I crazy?
It did say less.
Oh wait!
Animal needs less grass long.
I can't read.
These guys are divas for real!
Less grass long.
Um.
Less...
There's like no other...
I can't take away any more grass long from you guys.
That's it.
It's all gone.
It's been mowed.
It will never be...
It will never grow again.
Huh.
It's so mysterious.
Anyway.
We need some more nature.
Do you think they want a pond?
We can do that.
Construction.
What?
What the hell is this?
Terrain.
Sculpting.
I discovered some grass long.
Wait!
Where did this come from?
I'm sorry?
How?
Some of the grass short might be long in disguise.
I can't believe we discovered the grass long!
Wait.
What do we need more of?
Maybe some more sand.
Remove all green.
But they need some grass.
Grass.
Maybe there's like parts that are just so like minuscule grass long, you know?
Let's do some more rock.
Oh my gosh, it's going down for real.
What's actually happening?
These guys are divas.
It worked!
Important alert.
Uh-oh.
What's wrong?
Can't find an accessible keeper hut with space.
What are you talking about?
Diseased?
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Why are you diseased?
Hold on.
Uh...
How do I hire people again?
A zoo.
Uh...
Veterinarian.
Take care of my pet.
Oh, I can't...
I can't put them in there.
Go!
They're running?
Okay, good.
They're running.
No!
He feels so bad!
He has Campy Lobacteroseus!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Park is closed, everybody.
Go home!
Okay, let's do some more nature.
We'll make them happy.
Do they want water?
I guess it doesn't say.
But I can put some water in the...
Terrain.
Here we go.
This is snow water.
Obstructed.
By what?
Secret tall grass.
That's so scary.
Where does it come from?
Oh my god.
I don't think I like that.
Okay.
Water.
No, I saw it.
Obstructed where?
Please.
Please, my guys are thirsty.
Oh, mate.
They don't have any things...
Any ways to eat, do they?
Okay, hold on.
How...
What do they require?
What do you require to eat?
Oh, he's not hungry at all.
Mate.
Enrichment.
Here we go.
You want a...
A pumpkin?
Oh, yeah.
You want some...
Bedding with some large leaves?
Hmm.
It doesn't care about that.
You want, uh...
A blood scent marker?
Oh, they like that.
Here, put them by the guests.
Put it by the guests.
Oh, yeah.
You smell all those...
All that fresh, fresh meat, baby.
Don't get too close, everyone.
That hole isn't just for show.
A large ball.
Nice.
Okay, they have lots of enrichment now.
Um...
Let's do...
Large water bowl.
Um...
We'll do a place for their food, which can go...
On the...
On, uh...
Here?
Nope, that's water.
Food tray...
Large.
Perfect.
He he he.
Ha ha ha.
Why are there people at my zoo at like 2 in the morning?
I think he misses his friend.
He's restless.
It's okay, he'll be okay.
It's okay.
He'll be okay.
Look at the way he moves.
I wanna pet that guy.
Komodo dragon.
He's sniffing.
Smell the blood.
He smells the blood.
Where is he going?
His habitat sucks.
He needs more...
Oh, he needs hard shelter.
Okay.
Uh...
More plants.
I like this one.
It's nice and big.
Um, maybe...
Whoa.
This one's even bigger.
Um...
Whoa!
Sorry.
They just keep getting bigger.
There you go, buddy.
Facility has significant negative effects.
What are you talking about?
High amounts of litter.
Oh my god!
Is the janitor not doing his job?
Okay, we need trash cans.
What are you doing?
Heading to habitat...
What do you got?
What are you running for?
Why are we running?
What do you have?
What do you have in your hands?
Bins.
Okay.
Oh, we need...
Facilities.
Oh, bins.
We need a creepy bin.
Spooky.
Like this.
The twilight bin.
Hot dog.
Yeah.
You think people like my zoo?
We can see what they think.
How are you feeling about my zoo?
Hunger.
Thirsty.
Well, there's...
What are you doing?
Waiting for a vet surgery.
Oh!
That's the staff!
Oops.
He's just been carrying around.
Oh my god.
That's so sad.
Vet surgery.
Oh, here we go.
I'll put it here.
And then we'll build a path.
How do I build it?
Nobody can read that.
Nobody read that.
We could still save him.
Oh, there's a bathroom here.
Oops.
I thought it was on the other side.
Where does this go to then?
Oh.
It does.
Okay.
Akbar.
Oh.
Wait, why did you die?
I thought it was the guy in surgery.
Oh, hold on.
Pez, I think one's out.
I take good care of my pets.
Don't worry.
Oh.
Wait.
What?
We see him in the sunrise.
Oh.
Yay.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
He came back at his friend's...
Don't.
No.
This is so...
I think he was old.
Wait, this guy's 17.
So sad.
Wait, what's a hard shelter?
Shelter space is critically insufficient to cover all animals.
What's a hard shelter?
Look, he's licking the blood.
I guess like a cave.
Okay.
Hold on, Pez.
Come here.
Hold on.
I gotta give this guy a facility.
Where he'll die apparently.
Okay, shelter.
You wanna cave?
Yeah.
Give you a...
I gave him a bed.
Where you want to go?
We'll give him this wooden shelter.
This size is good.
But he probably wants something and people can't see him, right?
Whoa.
Maybe like this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Okay, are you happy with this?
Everything green!
Green!
We're in the green, baby.
We're in the green.
Let's buy a new dragon.
What?
He's meowing at me.
What are you doing, bro?
Search Komodo dragon.
We have another guy that is... Oh, wait.
Stop!
What are you doing?
What?
She's acting out because she wants out.
What do the leaves mean?
We have to replace them.
We have to.
You think we're getting enough money from these or...?
Largest donation, $20!
$80!
Top species donation!
What do you think of my zoo?
Oh.
Oh!
We need education!
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Education, education.
What are these?
Where is education under?
Blueprints?
No.
Woo, spooky tree!
We get a spooky tree here.
This is... this is nice.
Yeah.
Decoration.
Oh, we gotta educate them.
We gotta... the people want... knowledge!
Hold on, pies.
Hold on!
The people want knowledge!
Guest facility?
Oh, we need them to take out more money.
Uneven placement.
What do you mean?
Oh, you... no.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, here we go.
Take out money so that you can donate.
The tree of knowledge.
Chief... beef!
Wait.
I saw it.
It worked for a second.
The people want beef?
There we go.
How do I educate them?
The people are dumb.
The people are so stupid.
The people need to know.
Don't bully the people.
I have to.
Viewing dome?
Whoa.
Wait.
So we can dig underground and have people come view in the dome.
That's exciting.
Okay, hold on.
Information.
Projection screen.
Information counter.
No?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What is this?
Hashtag free pause.
Are you... are you doing out little girl?
Little ball.
What are you laying on?
Oh my gosh.
She is my little hunter.
I... she...
Paws is so great.
So...
Um...
Last night...
She was staring at something.
And I was like...
Usually when she stares like that, it's...
It's gonna be a bug.
And it's starting to get warm outside.
So all the bugs are coming...
Into my maid cafe.
They think it's abandoned.
But no!
I'm haunting it!
Anyway...
She was staring at...
I have this...
I...
Oh, she was staring at my bookshelf.
And I was like...
What does she see?
What could be there?
And...
Um...
I was...
Looking at my bookshelf.
And I was like...
I don't see anything.
Like, I was bending over.
Looking under.
Looking over.
And...
Then...
I'm like...
Standing there in silence.
And I hear like this...
Faint...
Crinkle.
Faint little rustle.
And I was like...
Oh wait...
I think there is something...
There.
She does see something.
I thought maybe...
Something caught her eye.
That like...
She...
Mistook for something else?
I don't know.
But uh...
I was like...
Oh...
Something is here.
And I have a...
A fake bouquet of flowers.
It's a...
I got it at a convention.
It's like a bouquet of flowers...
Made out of...
Like...
They're like...
Crocheted flowers.
And...
I...
That was what was rustling.
That was...
It was the plastic from the bouquet.
And...
I look in there...
And in between...
Like the folds...
Of the...
What is keeping together...
The bouquet...
Is a...
Cockroach!
It's a cockroach!
He was hiding in there!
So I had to...
Pick it up...
Like I...
Sealed it...
So that I couldn't get out...
And then I...
Took it out...
And went...
With...
So...
I...
It was gross!
See if you can buy snakes.
I don't think you can!
I didn't see any snakes.
How are you doing, Pies?
She's fine.
Is he fine?
Is this guy okay?
Oh yeah!
He's good!
He's 4 out of 5 stars, baby!
She...
Apply or remove contraception...
Where's the other guy?
Where is our other dragon?
Excuse me...
Oh, he's in here...
Injured!
Um...
Why do my dragons keep getting injured?
Oh, they're running, they're running...
Look at him go!
Did you see him run to this?
It was so cute!
He's got a problem to spell her in the...
Oh, you can...
You can inspect him from...
Over there?
Okay!
You're the professional!
Oh!
Serious injury discovered!
Uh-oh!
Run!
Run to the vet!
Run to the surgery!
Run!
What was the injury, I wonder?
Can't find an accessible keeper hut with space.
What are you talking about?
You guys keep calling it a raura.
Raura.
No.
It's a raura.
You need quarantine.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
It assigned it for me.
That's easy, I suppose.
Right there.
Nope.
Oops.
No, no, no, no.
I said I needed it.
I need the quarantine.
Right there.
Right...
Okay, let me let my cat out.
Okay.
She has been freed.
She has been freed, everybody.
You need a quarantine.
I already got one.
Wait, do I need to...
Have like a...
A path way to it?
This side?
Oh, oops.
I built it backwards.
That's fine.
They can...
They can go and take a little walk.
Take a hike.
Okay.
Is my guy back?
Did they fix him?
Oh!
They fixed her!
Okay.
Nice.
We need a keeper hut.
What are you talking about?
I already have one.
Right here.
This is not a keeper hut.
Oh wait, this is the trade center.
This is...
This is the hut.
Staff room.
Oh my god.
The people want...
Better educated guests will spend more cash.
Okay.
Speakers, audio guides.
Uh...
Okay, speakers.
Oh, we could put some benches too.
Oh, not Zuki.
Oh, Twilight.
We want everything spooky.
Oh, a spooky canopy.
I like it.
Uh...
What's this?
Spooky picnic bench.
I like it.
Uh...
Later.
Spooky bench.
I like it.
I...
Obstructed.
By who?
By what?
I don't think so.
I don't think it's obstructed at all.
You're ruining my...
Good time.
Please.
Oh, here we go.
Wait, but then you'll be facing away from the...
From the iguanas.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
What is it obstructed by?
Komodo dragons.
I said iguanas.
The dragons.
What time is it anyway?
It's midnight.
Go home.
It's 1am.
Security.
Uh...
Education.
Here we go.
Visual.
Visual media.
Anything.
Habitat web?
That's made for me.
Oh, people are gonna go crazy over that.
Education board.
We found it.
Oh, wait.
Undo.
Z.
Here we go.
Okay.
We'll put one next to each.
Uh...
I also feel like we should be blasting...
Here we are.
Ambience.
Not ambience.
Educational speaker.
Here we go.
Everybody needs it here.
Besides...
Beside each and every donation box.
Very nice.
The education is happening.
Why?
Still zero.
Hi to my favorite freaky med.
Parasocial hours.
What do you mean?
Oh.
Educational content non...
Komodo dragon.
There we go.
Oh, I have to do it for every single one.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Wait, where did I...
Where did I put them all?
Let's turn on our...
Here we go.
There we go.
Oh yeah.
We have...
We are reaching...
Levels that...
Have never been reached before.
In terms of education.
Oh yeah.
And then this also needs to have a thing about...
Komodo dragons.
No?
Oh, I can't?
Get delete.
Get rid of that.
Huh.
Wait, I missed some?
Get educated.
Everyone will know about the Komodo dragon.
Oh.
Okay.
That should be good.
All right.
Everybody should be really feeling fulfilled now.
The education is only at...
10%.
What do you mean?
Why?
Maybe they're not far in enough.
Zero.
Okay.
That's just your ear...
You're...
You have retention problems then.
You're just not listening.
You're just not doing a very good job.
I'm allergic to knowledge.
No!
Only 10%.
Guys, what are we doing wrong?
Our zoo is really only at...
One and a half stars.
No educational content.
Maybe...
We were wrong to call you Sesame Street for 30 year olds.
Do we need different boards on the wall?
I tried to put those, but...
Nothing worked.
Like I couldn't...
I couldn't...
Oh wait, we gotta do our tunnel too.
Let's do that.
Let's get our tunnel going.
Oh!
What is this?
Whoa!
Do-do-loo!
Do-do-do!
Boop-boop-boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
What's up?
We'll do a ramp.
I think we have to go from here.
Okay.
Ignore the ground here.
Smooth it over, smooth it over.
Where'd the grass come from?
They hate the grass.
Tuarego, thank you so much for the vibe.
Good to take you.
An escape tunnel.
No, no, no, no.
Hey, how are you feeling about your habitat?
Too much long grass, right?
You're hungry and thirsty?
Well, eat then.
Why are you hungry and thirsty?
Oh, oh, oh no.
Wait.
What's wrong?
You need a key?
Is it the keeper hut?
Is that what's wrong?
Okay, hold on.
Oh wait, we need it over here.
I can't do it on the hill, I think.
Okay, if we do it here.
Like that.
I think.
This should be fine.
And then... path.
This way.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
No.
No, no, no, no.
No, please.
I think I have to get rid of some of our donation.
Okay, okay, okay.
Path.
No!
My car!
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Thank you!
Oh, ah.
I did it.
Okay.
Awesome.
I have a quarantine!
What do they need from me?
What else do they want?
I'll do another one, I guess.
They're so picky.
It's like they have, like, standards of living for these creatures or something, you know?
God.
Did you eat yet?
Did you eat?
Is everything good?
No.
Where's our zookeeper?
Why does he suck?
Nobody outpeaches the hut.
I can't run.
Okay.
Let's continue our tunnel.
That doesn't really work, huh?
Why does it sound so wet?
Wait.
Chisel?
There we go, there we go, okay.
We just gotta...
smooth it over.
Smooth, smooth.
There we go, okay.
Alright.
You think you could fit in there?
It's...
It's a mouse simulator.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, we're digging.
Dig.
Dig, dig, dig.
Push, push, push.
Push, push.
We'll find the dome eventually.
Okay, okay.
This is good, this is good.
Push, push.
Just like my mama says.
Push.
I don't know where the dome is.
It looks like an eyeball.
It's kind of freaky.
Why did I make it so far inward?
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is good.
Maybe we start from here.
What the hell is this?
Dangerous animal?
Wait, who escaped?
Wait.
Huh?
How?
Wait.
Who escaped?
Where?
Um...
How?
Uh...
Wait.
Who escaped?
Oh!
How did he get out?
I think he destroyed the fence.
He's so chill.
The vet is not doing anything.
It's...
Uh...
Um...
Where are you?
Oh.
That was a...
That was a paying customer.
Um...
Uh...
Oh!
Wait a second.
You...
Emergency captures a thousand bucks?
Well...
I guess...
Oh...
Luckily we have...
Um...
Where's the other guy?
I guess luckily we have unlimited money.
Dangerous animal.
It's a dragon.
They're so dramatic.
They are so dramatic.
What was that?
Oh!
Wait.
What happened to our guys?
Oh, they're putting them back inside?
But, um...
There's a giant hole in the fence.
I don't think it works.
Wait, there's a viewing dome!
We can do that.
Obstructed.
Hold on.
Get rid of you.
Can I?
Delete.
Okay, and then...
Barrier.
Oh, I saw it.
It worked for just a second.
For a brief moment.
Hmm...
Never mind.
I give up.
Let's try...
Uh...
Steel mesh?
No?
Oh, here we go.
Perfect.
Oh, this one's not broken.
So, surely nothing will get out.
Okay.
Unbox all animals.
They're fine.
See?
Happy people.
Everybody's happy.
Happy...
Happy dragons.
Gosh, I really thought they got out from the hole for a second.
I was kind of scared.
Okay, but I have to figure out also how to get...
From this hole.
Why are they so...
Why are they seem really determined to get to the hole?
Wait a second.
Does this fence look...
Like, even more...
Destroy...
They sensed freedom!
They knew!
How to get to it!
Okay, let's uh...
Uh...
Let's fix this again...
Our steel mesh...
Wait...
What if I also make them higher?
There we go.
Nice.
Okay.
And I see this part too...
Wait, how do I...
Just...
Just stick it in there.
Right in this...
There we go.
Yep.
Okay.
All is good.
All is well.
These might break eventually...
But...
For right now...
We have a tunnel to focus on.
Okay?
Oh my gosh.
Kuya!
Thank you so much for...
The 50 gift!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Push, push, push.
We're pushing the dirt.
We'll make it to the...
Wait, how close are we?
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck in the ground.
There we go.
Oh yeah!
I was gonna start from over here.
This would probably be better.
Start from here.
Oh, no!
Um...
I'm struggling!
Wait, maybe we do this.
This might be...
The better option.
Wait, hold on.
Imagine...
Coming out of the bathroom...
And seeing like...
The exhibit completely open.
How do you feel about it?
I love that...
Toilet...
Block 3...
Cost nothing!
I wish I could have...
Stayed longer...
To see the Komodo dragon.
You could!
You can!
Where are they?
Where are my...
Oh, I never...
I never...
Release them!
Oops!
Charge the toilet?
Yeah...
What makes them happy?
How do I...
How do I make it not free?
Hmm...
I renamed it to the paid toilet.
Oh, here we go.
Price.
A dollar.
Super excited for Off-Kai.
Thank you, Tonies!
Thank you!
Yeah, we've been losing money on the toilet.
Honestly...
We gotta...
Have people pay to use it.
I wish I could...
See anything.
When it gets dark, it's so hard to...
Tell what's going on.
Oh my god.
Everything's falling apart.
Everything is falling apart!
You guys!
Yes.
And...
To here?
More?
How...
Why can't I...
Why is this so hard?
Why is this so hard to build?
I don't understand it.
Huh.
That's the only way I know how to do it.
Wait, is this broken too?
No.
I can't see anything.
This is broken.
No.
Yes.
Okay.
Alright.
What just happened?
Oh!
Oh, they're getting restless.
I'm sorry!
They were restless!
Oh my gosh.
Dada was just like, I'm too old if we kept in this box!
I don't know any public toilets that you have to pay to use.
Uh, this is not a public toilet.
It's a toilet of...
A um...
Of a...
Of a zoo.
Okay, here we go.
Let's go back to our...
To our...
To our mission.
It's turning out great, you guys.
It's turning out great.
Uh...
That don't...
That doesn't look very good.
Um, what's going on here?
Um...
There's no mechanics in the zoo.
It's like really close to the tree.
Oh, wait.
Where...
What broke?
Aw, man.
How did it break?
There we go.
Perfect.
Running a zoo is hard, you guys.
I gotta get a mechanic in here, too.
Okay, you better go like, fix the...
He's running.
He's like, why didn't you call me sooner?
We were two seconds away from a fire.
Park has no maintenance.
An educator.
We need like three of you.
Okay, do your jobs.
Educate the people.
I have keepers and mechanics and...
And such.
We're fine.
Aw.
Aw, they're so active.
So active.
Oh, this thing's about to deteriorate, huh?
Oh.
Oh, he's damaging the barriers.
Wow, they really want to get free.
Keep doing it.
Which one is this?
Who is this?
Who's damaging the barrier?
Inten.
He says, screw you, chain link fence.
Where's the other guy at?
Raura!
Where are you?
Oh, there they are.
They're planning.
They're scheming.
They're plotting.
They know what to do to break the fet- Look at this.
She really is just like, I'm dead.
When night falls and nobody is watching...
We'll burn it down.
Planning her escape.
The music is so...
Mysterious.
Aw.
So cute.
The animal models look really good in this game.
The tug.
Oh, he's so sweet.
Should give him a bed.
Is this not their bed?
This little pile of leaves?
I think they like it.
How do you feel?
Do you feel educated little kid?
43% of knowledge.
You're hungry?
Oh, I think our...
I think our...
People...
They want food.
Wait, but we have a...
We have a chief beef right here.
There.
Why is it losing money?
Uh-oh.
Why does it keep saying I need a quarantine?
I have one.
I'm so confused.
Okay, I have a second one.
Weird.
Finally, that...
Um...
That, uh...
That notification is gone.
Because it's not a quarantine.
What?
It is!
Oh, it's a research center.
How did Kevin James make this look easy?
Who dat?
Who's Kevin?
What?
Let's um...
Let's see what we got for our twilight.
We're gonna keep making our spooky...
Our spooky place.
Twilight pack.
I paid money for this.
Uh, nature?
Barriers.
Facilities.
Uh, everything.
Everything.
A walkthrough exhibit.
Whoa!
Um...
Wherever we can put it.
Right...
Here.
Where does it lead to?
That's a great question.
Many have often wondered.
What was in here, anyway?
Oh, rocks!
What if we filled it with snakes?
Let's see if we can get some.
The market.
Minto...
Plays Planet Zoo.
Also Minto plays Minecraft in Planet Zoo.
Hi Minky, got any tapirs?
We can get one.
I guess we don't have snakes after all, do we?
Which I totally feel like those should be in the...
In the spooky Twilight pack, but...
Hmm...
Disappointing, disappointing.
Why is this one so expensive and this one so cheap?
Hmm...
What can I put in here?
A hippo?
A monkey.
Invalid destination.
Uh oh.
I think I bought...
Wrong guy.
Uh...
Quick tread.
Take him back.
Uh...
I do return.
Return to sender.
Let's make a tapir...
Here.
Okay, so we do this.
Path...
This will be a pathway surrounding the uh...
The tapir exhibit.
Like so.
Okay.
Now barriers.
What's a guest gate?
Tipir are...
Are harmless little fellas.
So they could have a...
Uh...
This...
This one.
Like this.
I want that thing.
Wait, what is it?
Why is it brick?
Wait, you won't be able to see them.
Wait.
You won't be able to see them.
What sound does the tapir make?
Uh...
Does this work?
I don't understand.
I don't know.
Wait, I can add windows, no?
Uh...
Link to a viewing dome.
Oh...
Wait, is that how that works?
No way.
Wait, where's the dome?
Construction...
Where... Where was the dome?
Negative effects?
What is it?
This?
They don't like the transformer?
What?
Do they expect us to not have electricity?
Are they dumb?
I don't remember how we found the...
The dome.
Dome.
Oh wait, there are lights!
Oh!
Oh my gosh, finally.
We'll make them spooky.
Whoa!
A beacon.
Spooky.
Wait, these say mushrooms, but are they...
Light up mushrooms, or...
Whoa, this thing's huge!
Wow!
That's cool!
Oh, oh.
Are they lit up?
I think, um...
We have a fungus problem.
Um...
This one...
Definitely, it looks like it would...
Give you some sort of disease.
Okay.
Uh...
Dome.
Oh, floor lights.
Watch out for the fire, everybody!
Watch out for the fire!
Hold your children!
Decal bat.
How's that work?
It looks like a slug to me.
I feel I should maybe become a...
A decorator.
Of the interior and exterior kind.
There's a...
There was a video that was cracking me up the other day.
It's like these two ladies...
I guess from the 90s or something...
That do interior decorating.
And...
They just actually ruin everything that they touch.
They did one of a house where they were painting the wooden floor.
They were painting the wooden floor and they were just like...
Well...
If you...
Um...
Don't want to get a carpet.
You can just paint the floor instead.
And so they painted a carpet...
That was...
Purple, yellow, and red.
With black diamonds all around it.
It was...
It's...
It's so bad.
It's actually...
Way worse than I'm even describing it.
Like...
It's...
Terrible.
Wait.
I didn't mean to do that.
Who are you?
Do you like my place?
Oh, I thought you were an alien for a second.
You're thirsty.
You're going to go pee.
Ain't nothing to lose.
You like my place?
You like my...
Pad?
Can I...
Can people come to my...
Zoo?
How would you be able to come to my zoo?
Wait, where'd you go?
There you are.
Just slurping.
Well...
Alright, how's your...
How's your education?
33%.
You're stupid.
You have...
You actually do have nothing to lose.
Because you have no brain cells.
Wow, traffic jam.
Right here.
What the hell?
The ticket price is fair.
Why does that make you upset?
Wait, you've been at my zoo for a month?
How long have you been here?
Okay, this month.
Okay.
I gotta find the dome so that we can open this up.
Special effects.
Ambiance.
Special effect.
Dirt falling.
I think the patrons would really enjoy that.
Oh yeah, the patrons would really love the immersion of...
Dirt falling on their head.
I've been standing there for weeks.
Who are you?
Oops.
Oh, I'm trying to click on her.
I'm just trying to click on her.
I need...
Oh, oh, oh.
Ice monkey to get the zoo five stars.
Look, we're at...
We're at almost two stars though.
Who are you?
Oh...
You're an educator.
Oh, okay.
Clunk, clunk.
Let's see.
Dome.
What was it under, you guys?
I can't remember at all.
Dome.
I don't know.
Oh, oh.
The viewing dome.
I got it.
Okay.
Now that...
Viewing dome.
Oh, place dome entrance.
Is that not this?
We
got the entrance?
Now let's bring in the tapirs.
People will be so like...
What could this be?
They'll be like...
What is this exhibit?
I can't see inside of it unless I go in.
Adopt.
Okay, send....
Send, send, send.
Uh...
Wait, where are you?
Oh here we go.
Send, send, send.
Send.
Okay.
Then we'll see what they need once they're here.
Hurry up.
Oh, wow.
The mushrooms really do light up a lot.
Let's put some over here, too, then.
Facilities.
No.
Habitat?
What was it under?
Oh, gosh.
Why is it so hard to find anything in this game?
Content pack.
Twilight pack.
They need nightmares to feed off of.
And so they will get.
Hey, why don't these light up?
Hey, wait a second.
Wait a second.
Why aren't they lighting up?
My little jack-o-lanterns.
Oh, they're running.
Okay, what do you need?
More grass short.
Okay.
So far, it's a good amount.
But we're just getting rid of that long grass.
We hate the long grass.
Nobody wants long grass.
We need more soil.
Long grass hate.
Hate, hate, hate.
Great.
Okay.
Awesome.
And we're still gotta get rid of the long grass.
We'll do more soil.
Why is there so much long grass everywhere?
Oh, they're screaming.
I think we're...
They're so picky.
Eww.
Oh, I see some long grass.
They, like, see one grass blade get too high and they're like,
What?
Serious injury?
Vet!
Call the vet!
Wait, how do I call the vet?
Oh, overpopulation.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Outsider.
Oh, um,
is there mental health of serious injury?
Okay, uh, anyway.
What else do you need?
Hard shelter.
Yes.
South Central America.
Oh, wait.
Um, is this... can I... by content?
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
Bramble.
You like that?
You like this?
You like the bramble bush?
You like a bramble bush for?
More bramble?
You like that?
You need a shelter?
You want some rocks?
A climbing rock?
You want a rock here?
Big ol' rock?
You like it?
Um...
Bramble anyone?
Yeah.
They need more plants.
Let's get some... some bootin... b-b-b-boot... bootalia.
And then I broke a bad tree.
Okay, plants are getting there.
Plants are getting there.
More broken tree.
Can we get a big tree in here?
Oh, we could get a vine.
Okay.
Whoa!
Big tree.
Alright!
Wait, but... how did we fix the problem?
I said their injury was due to overpopulation.
Matured or introduced into overpopulated habitat.
Um... Hmm... Facility.
It has to be there!
Everybody is just such sensitive babies.
Babies.
You think anyone's gonna come see the tapir?
Or... Why don't they... Why not?
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, you're a security guard.
Oh, you're a keeper.
Wait, why aren't people coming to see the tapir?
Did I plant these outside the... Oops.
My bad.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna pause...
Uh... Before, so that things don't become released.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I can do this.
Let's do this.
Watch, watch, watch.
Watch and learn.
Oh.
That's a gate.
Um... Watch and learn.
Watch and learn.
More steel mesh.
Bigger.
Oh.
Wait, where'd my steel mesh go?
Just kidding.
No more steel mesh.
Okay, now it's bigger.
It's not overpopulated now, is it?
Uh... Grass long too much.
Yeah, I feel that too.
We need more soil.
More soil!
Everybody can just go into the tube and then they'll see the tapir.
That's all they have to do.
What's this?
Navigable swimming area.
Okay.
We construct.
Wait, how did I do that again?
Oh, terrain.
Here we go.
Uh... There was like the ones... Oh, here we go.
The stamp.
Yeah, yeah.
There's no viewing space.
But the tunnel!
Wait!
People are going in!
It's working!
It's... Oh.
I think I just killed that guy.
There's people inside!
Oh my god!
Whoa!
They're up and close with them!
It's almost like...
...the people...
...are the exhibit to the tapir.
There.
Um...
Okay.
Water.
Terrain.
Yeah!
There you go!
Oh yeah!
I just...
I just killed that guy.
Oops!
No, no, no!
More water!
Water!
Okay.
Very good.
This guy is giving him a show, huh?
How is there still overpopulation?
I think we're gonna have to sell one off.
I think.
Can you put more domes?
Let's try.
That's a good idea.
What was it under?
Habitat?
Yeah.
That's the dome entrance.
Okay.
I am inside the dome entrance to Habitat.
And it's great!
Well, they're running.
They're happy.
Except they're not.
But like, not really.
Water reduces area.
Maybe I should have made it smaller.
But it said that they...
Oh, shelter, shelter, shelter.
Um...
Shelter, shelter.
Oh, food and water.
Feeding station.
I don't know how to tell what they need for their food and...
You know?
Doesn't really explain much.
In terms of that.
Like, it just said that they need it.
And I'm like, well, which one do they need?
Enrichment!
Um...
Beds and shelter.
Do they burrow, or...?
Do they just want some leaf?
You can use the filters?
Oh, by species?
Oh, that's helpful.
I didn't even realize there was that.
Uh...
It starts with a B, right?
There we go.
Aha!
Oh my god, they're swimming!
That's so cute!
This thing's huge.
Perfect.
And now, enrichment.
Which, uh...
Where?
Gardening.
Animal exhibit?
No.
Where was it again?
Habitat.
Oh, enrichment!
I knew that.
They want a tire.
They want that...
Uh...
Scratching tree!
That's always fun.
Oh, see?
Yeah, yeah!
People are using both now!
Awesome.
Heh heh heh heh!
Okay, this is too big.
A rubbing pillar?
They would like that, right?
Uh...
Why can't I place it anywhere?
Right?
Uh...
I saw it light up for a second.
I don't think they need all this water.
Heh heh heh heh.
Right there.
Perfect.
Enrichment, 50%.
Herb scent marker.
Okay.
That didn't do much.
Large barrel feeder.
Like that.
A box?
They like that?
Okay.
Someone's gonna have to leave.
And I think it's gonna have to be...
This one.
The tapirs demand a 5090.
I can't do it!
Mr. Bright, thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you!
Send animal to storage.
Sayonara.
Send to...
...to storage.
Sayonara.
I guess we'll only have two tape here.
Sad.
Aww.
I wanted a bunch of them.
Unless I made the whole facility tape here.
Goodbye.
Why are people upset about my zoo?
What are the guests unhappy about?
Look how many unhappy people there are.
What are you unhappy about?
These facility buildings are ruining my experience of the zoo.
There has to be facility buildings.
Like you just...
You just have to...
Why aren't there any benches?
Oh.
The people yearn to sit.
The people yearn for a place to rest...
They're feet.
High amounts of litter.
Where?
Uneven placement.
The people's feet's hurt.
What just happened?
Wait.
Why is there a disease risk?
What is this?
What is that?
I think I need to hire more people.
Let's hire some more zookeepers.
Get in here.
Fix it up.
I don't know why I'm being stingy when I have unlimited money.
I have unlimited money.
And yet.
Wait.
Were both tapir removed?
No.
Here's one.
Habitat.
Moderate environmental welfare.
The cleanliness.
Oh.
Is it these?
They don't like the herb things or...
I think it highlighted those.
They were like, that's nasty.
Nobody wants that in here.
Um.
Nobody wants it.
Are you happy?
I didn't come here to see the staff facilities.
These people are so, like...
Stingy, no?
No.
I think the tapir are pooping.
Hoppity hoppo.
There isn't much to see in this zoo.
We have literally the two best animals in the world.
Oh, I forgot about...
Are you doing okay?
Oh, his habitat's like 99%.
He doesn't care about this tall grass at all.
Oh, let's see the donation boxes.
Donations.
Everybody send in your donations.
Or else we'll have to go bankrupt.
Where is the donation?
Donations.
Where was it again?
I won't be able to feed my family without your donations.
Education soundboard.
That's huge.
Boom, boom, boom.
Where...
Where is the donation?
This zoo needs memberships.
Oh, yeah.
I would get a lifetime membership for this zoo.
I would, I would, I would.
Oh, how cute.
River.
Transport.
Suspended gondola.
I'll complete.
I think it's good.
Oh, you can do it.
You can do it.
Oh, it's almost there.
Oh my God.
It's almost there.
Oh, oh.
Missed the mark, buddy.
This is the best gondola ride ever.
Oh.
Build one kilometer of a tracked ride.
Nice.
Does it just, uh...
End?
The game is trying to kill my patrons.
I didn't realize you were playing roller coaster tycoon.
I didn't realize you were playing roller coaster.
Whoa.
Oh.
Please.
Let me back into my...
The camera is...
Oh, please.
Let me back into my park.
Please.
Please let me back into my park.
I wish to be a part of my park.
Please.
Let me in.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
Awesome.
I think we need, uh...
A pathway to this.
How do you actually use...
How do you...
How do we connect this?
Maybe here?
How do people use it?
I'm actually not quite sure.
Um...
Oh.
Mysterious.
Quite a vista, eh?
I know.
We have the most beautiful...
Park in the world.
Despite what...
Guests...
They don't like...
Any of these buildings.
They're so ridiculous.
But look.
The happy faces.
Incomplete track.
I tried.
Okay, hold on.
Let's try it again.
Um...
How do I...
Uh...
Edit track.
There we go.
Okay.
Auto-complete.
Oh, jeez.
I just...
I don't know where it's trying to go.
Uh...
Hmm.
Minto, what have you done?
Nothing.
I'm trying to enhance my park.
It's not my fault that the...
The AI sucks.
X-ray of my tapeworm.
Like,
where is it supposed to go?
I think to the entrance, no?
Hmm...
It'll get there.
It's almost there.
Why doesn't it just go around?
Oh, wow.
It's...
They're really taking the long way.
They've passed the entrance, like, five times now.
I don't know.
So close.
Oh my god.
We're over there.
Oh, nope.
So close.
I don't think I can get out of this either.
I think I'm stuck in this mode.
Oh.
Whoa.
Wait.
It created a...
Is that inside the tape here?
Oh my gosh.
We're so close.
Okay.
Hold on.
Now from here...
Okay.
Hold on.
From here, start test.
There it goes so slowly.
We could change the color.
That's exciting.
I'll change it to...
Minto.
Okay.
Hold on.
Maybe I'll...
Maybe I have to build another station.
Right?
Is it sick?
Oh my god.
Did you hear that?
It was my tummy around.
I'm hungry.
Here we go.
I think it needs...
It's trying to go back to where...
Oh.
That's why.
Wait.
This one's so nice though.
You'll get the whole view.
Yeah.
I want to get off.
This...
This wild ride.
Wait.
Where did the gondola go?
Is it still traveling?
Oh.
Yep.
Nice and slow.
Can I ride it too?
Guys.
I have interest.
I'm riding with...
With...
Wait.
I'm...
I'm on top of the...
Wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't like that part.
Whoa, whoa.
I'm in the seat.
Wait.
I want to look around.
Stop.
This is so exciting.
Max speed.
We're on the ride.
Oh.
Whoopsie.
Where'd it go?
Oh.
Oh, there it is.
The music is so dramatic.
Let me look around.
Wow.
Wait.
We're going to see the tapirs.
Where are they?
I guess over there.
We're blocking, like, all the mountain view.
I guess they're trying to be safe, you know?
Very cozy, right?
Oh, there's even ways you can look down.
Oh my gosh.
A castle.
Oh, I can see people from here.
Oh, they're just little ants from all the way up here.
Yeah, they're just little ants.
Ant people.
We're going to pass over the tape here.
Oh.
Oh, it's shuffling.
Is this what Tokyo Disney is like?
Oh my gosh, there they are.
There's one.
There's an animal.
Wow.
Where'd he go?
Someone was playing with the barrel.
And it's taking us somewhere else.
When you let Highlander Academy design your zoo.
This feels like an ad.
Like ad shots.
Hold on.
I'm going to have a snack real quick.
I'm going to have a cheese okaki.
It's going to be a little crunchy while we watch this.
It's broken.
No.
I can see a Komodo dragon from here.
Wait.
Aren't we nearing the end?
Stop the test.
The dramatic shot of it falling off the cliff.
Wow.
Worth every penny.
We can get this one working.
Test.
Here we go.
Wow, it's so beautiful.
Wow.
How do I change... Max speed is zero miles per hour.
How do I make it faster?
Let's see.
Hold on.
Oh, wow.
You can get really... Oh, wow.
You can get really...
Wait, we can do that to here then.
No?
And then that should make it able to be closed.
Let's see.
Uh-oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's like do right there.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Now...
Now... Now...
Auto-complete.
How do I...
Come here.
How do I do it?
Oh, shoot.
We just need to suggest the big gondola for all the angry patrons.
What a thrill!
Shuttle mode.
Oh!
Here we can change the max speed.
20 miles per hour, baby.
This one too.
Fast.
How do I...
I think it was...
Edit track.
There we go.
Okay.
Auto-complete.
Oh!
It worked!
Oh my gosh.
The best gondola ever!
Still seems kind of slow.
What about this one?
We max the speed?
Let's max the thrill.
Start the test.
Let's...
Let's see.
Pull...
Max speed...
20 miles per hour...
Oh!
Stop the test.
Get me off this ride.
Nice.
That was intense, wasn't it?
That was pretty crazy.
How are you guys doing?
Are you happy?
Your nutrition has moderate issues.
Last...
Meal quality.
My last meal tasted horrible.
I would like to complain about it.
His last meal quality was also terrible.
Oh my god, there's so much talking there.
Shut up, people.
What's going on there?
Give birth...
Are those your babies?
What?
Don't suck up the baby!
Wait, you're about to give birth?
Oh...
So...
Cute!
I got the miracle of life.
So cute!
Oh, a little dyslexic.
Oh!
No, I'll name you.
I wanna name you.
How do I name you?
Well...
Don't worry about it.
Oh my god, so stinking cute.
Oh!
He's excited.
I'm a dad!
Yeah, you are.
Guys...
I think that was a good place to end today on.
We watched...
The miracle of life.
We...
Created this...
Epic...
Gondola...
Oh, it's still going.
Wait, I wanna ride it.
Ride the gondola.
The joy of creation.
In not just...
Animals.
But also...
Gondolas.
Thank you for chill streaming though.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
This was fun.
And um...
The max speed got to 23 miles per hour!
Wait...
If we do a drop...
So if we have the...
There be a drop...
Would it go even faster?
There's our...
There's our magnificent, beautiful...
Little zoo.
But it's not little.
It's got...
A big heart.
It's got a big ol' heart.
Our zoo.
Into the lizard pit.
Final destination gondola.
This was fun, you guys!
Thank you so much for...
Um...
Just hanging out with me.
And letting me build my little zoo.
While I had tummy ache.
And um...
It's gonna be a little bit before my next stream.
Um...
So...
I'm sorry.
But I'll see you guys...
Uh...
Soon it'll be...
It'll be...
It'll come fast.
Unless...
Unless I see you at off-kai.
Then I'll see you at off-kai.
I have panels.
And a meet and greet.
And...
And uh...
Uh...
Yeah, that's about it.
Three panels!
Yeah.
And a meet and greet.
Super fun and chill stream.
Thank you!
See you at off-kai minto.
See you!
Thank you!
Really nice stream today, huh?
For the off-kai in Japan.
Thank you!
What is a...
Spit and greet?
You'll just...
Have to...
See!
Thank you so much for the off-kai-zuma!
Good luck with your work again in Japan!
Thank you!
My work...
I'll be...
I'll be less busy...
Soon!
TM!
Soon, TM!
Okay!
Thank you guys!
Have a good day, have a good night!
And I'll see you when I see you next!
Yeah!
Bye-bye!
It's gonna be so sad that I can't stream for a bit.
And then I won't have the 24 hour.
But...
As soon as I'm settled in Japan, I will stream.
Hmm...
So...
Don't you worry!
Otsumito!
Arigato!
Chuuu!
Thank you, Kava!
Thanks to the Chilled Zoo stream!
Thank you!
For watching me Chilled with Zoo!
Bye-bye!
Otsumito!